can you remember the times in those
films where it doesn't lose you and you
do not often go to sleep I mean is it
that you're not connected to the
characters is the dialogue forced well
it's not a moment it's it's the stuff
that leads up to the to a particular
moment I mean it's just not imaginative
it's well it might be a matter it's it's
not really integrated there are
filmmakers out there who are great at at
creating moments that are exciting and
kind of fun to look at the Coen Brothers
for example and I'm not a fan maybe I'm
I think stuff like this I think that
they are able to kind of dazzle you for
a moment with a crazy wacky thing that
happens and then another one and then
another one but after a while it's just
like a catalog of crazy things the
difference between them on one hand and
let's say Vince Gilligan and his writers
on the other or David chase and his
writers on the other hand and I'm
referring to them the founding voices
that drive The Sopranos and Breaking Bad
the examples we're talking about which I
consider to be really outstanding drama
models of great great great dramatic
narratives they create dazzling crazy
things too but they don't just abandon
it and go on to something else they if
you've seen the if you've seen Breaking
Bad you'll see stuff that from the first
season if it gets resurrected three four
seasons later you know it's hard work to
do that you gotta keep track of
everything you gotta make it sort of
coherent you see a movie like inherent
vice I mean you know it's it's just
blabbing you know crazy kind of people
being nutty and they're intense you know
but what's it about and I think they're
largely making it up as they go along I
can't believe that they're not
improvising a lot of that it takes work
on the part of the writer in fact it's
the hardest work in the world to create
a narrative
story where everything fits where you
where nothing can be thrown away and
there's nothing in it that you know
doesn't serve the story the purpose of
moving that store forward
you